my viral tick tocks skyrocketed in my
music career and this is that story is
that too like cartoony i'm lubilen i've
been making music since i was a kid
basically i used to live in ottawa which
is a few hours away from montreal where
i've been for the last like eight or
nine years and so i back then i was
working with an artist collective and we
were we were always just creating stuff
in little experiments and songwriting
and just exploring the things that i
think are interesting it's hard to to to
find an audience for sure for a long
time i was just kind of you know a
smaller group of people and it's still
super cool to have like 20 people
connect with your music even one person
is is sick but uh but yeah then that's
like it's a little harder to make a
living that way i was just making
tick-tocks to kind of promote my music i
was like oh okay tick tock is the the
place where everyone's
blowing up so uh let's try some tick
tocks and so i tried applying my talents
there i was doing like different little
acapella covers and i feel like tic toc
is the perfect place to test things
because if you make something and it
sucks no one sees it so it's fine i did
like the a little nas x like acapella
cover of uh holiday and that got me like
100 000 views then i did a different
acapella cover it got like 20 30k i was
like okay okay maybe we have to do
different things and i was like um i was
watching different creators i think i
saw somebody like singing the ingredient
list on like a container or something or
they were reading like the micro copy on
a soup can but like as a song and i was
like oh yeah you could literally make
anything and do a song and then i think
it was kind of just like well let's take
things the internet has already deemed
funny and then i'll do my thing on that
and then at least if it flops i'll know
it's my fault and not the fault of your
root content and just kind of trying to
find a thing that i could do and i was
like okay what if i take a a meme and
make a song and then
uh found the like is this available
screenshot and just took a stab at doing
the top line and keep in mind like we're
not not even an inkling of where it's
gonna go right and so i'm like filming
it and then it wasn't working i showed
it to my partner and she's like hey like
come on like we gotta redo this like get
the light right you know and so we
re-shot it put it up and i was like
let's see
[Music]
and uh within like an hour it had 100
000 views or something and then within
like two or three hours it was at like a
quarter mil and then like another hour
after that i was at a million and i was
like okay i think we got one and yeah
now it's at like 40 million or 40 some
million and i remember like being on a
walk with my partner being like okay we
just have to do it a second time if we
do it a second time then it's like
locked in but i did not know what we
were locking in it was
mayhem it was like the inbox was just
like filling with business opportunities
and [ __ ] so you're like okay like i
gotta start this out like the tonight's
show with jimmy fallon would like to you
know whatever it said and i was just
like oh my [ __ ] god like they just
wanted it to be like another internet
drama so like they didn't they didn't
have any notes for me they were like do
you have notes for us like jimmy's
amazing and allison breeze is phenomenal
it was a legit dream so yeah super cool
i'm really glad that i got the record
deal that i have before
becoming victor famous the record label
slash management team that i have now
found me when i had 400 followers it was
just like the right fit and it wasn't
about like virality or numbers so i've
got an ep out called the who's love ep
um with like a bunch of music videos
that we made that are all batch insane
that i'm so proud of i'm streaming on on
youtube right now every week it's been
hard it's been fun it's been scary it's
been exciting but i wouldn't change a
thing and thanks thanks for
listening to me talk
[Music]